so you're the tobacco industry in the
1900s you're the maker of the perfect
product cheap accessible easy to
manufacture and incredibly addictive
winston is the one built the cigarette
that delivers flavor 20 times a pack and
for the past couple decades demand for
your product has gone up so drastically
in 1910 the us was producing 10 billion
cigarettes a year by 1930 we were up to
123 billion that you're pretty much
swimming in money but then something
happens that threatens your entire
tobacco empire two reports published in
1953 and 1964 prove that there is a
direct link between smoking and cancer
and these were no ordinary reports
either they came straight from the
president of the american cancer society
and the us surgeon general suddenly your
entire business comes under attack
because it's unhealthy companies get
away with selling junk food that make
people die of obesity but smoking has to
go this was a major problem because if
people believed without a doubt that
their cigarettes would kill them they
may just quit
you need to sell doubt and disbelief you
need to make people want to believe your
side of the story your solution one of
the greatest marketing ploys to ever
fool the public
this is how they did it i earn a living
fronting an organization that kills one
thousand two hundred human beings a day
twelve hundred people we're talking two
jumbo jet plane loads of men women and
children
i mean there's attila
genghis
and me
[Music]
lucky strike
first again with tobacco men
first again with tobacco men
[Music]
so
meet edward bernice
a 25 year old austrian-born jew edward
bernays applied to enlist in the
military the very same day america
declared war on germany in 1917.
unfortunately his bad eyesight and flat
feet disqualified him from serving
but bernays was far from giving up you
see he had a natural talent for rallying
people behind great causes in other
words he was an expert at propaganda and
what better way to serve than by getting
more americans to support the war so he
talked himself into a position at the
committee of public information and set
to work he held rallies brought freedom
fighters to inspire people and got
massive companies like ford to
distribute pro-war brochures in the u.s
and abroad by the time the war was won
president woodrow wilson was so
impressed by edward's work he was
invited to the paris peace conference
all this got edward thinking if
propaganda could work for war couldn't
it also work for anything else and he
was right so he set out on propaganda
campaign after propaganda campaign
rebranded as public relations campaigns
earning him a reputation for being able
to get anyone to support pretty much
anything when he joined a company that
sold pork products he was tasked with
convincing the country that bacon and
eggs was an all-american breakfast and
to do so he got doctors to advocate that
heavier breakfast was healthier
edward bernays had discovered a
universal truth role models influence
desire whatever the role models we look
up to want we also want that same thing
when it comes to diet and health people
look up to doctors and bernays realized
that every industry has its own role
models and if he could just figure out
who they were and get them to advocate
for whatever product he was pushing he
was golden by the end of the 20s edward
bernays was a propaganda legend but his
most impressive propaganda campaign yet
was just about to start
in 1929 the president of the american
tobacco company came to edward for help
his business was doing well but there
was a completely untapped market he
wanted to break into women
see in the late 20's women smoking was
very frowned upon it was unlitty like
taboo that meant that if edward could
get women to start smoking tobacco
companies would literally double their
customer base so he started with
identifying why women smoking in public
was such a taboo he came to the
conclusion that cigarettes represented
male power what kind of a man is he i'm
a guy who likes to work on my car it
also happened to be the age of women's
rights so what better way to get women
to smoke than by taking the feminist
angle by smoking you're taking back your
freedom and power from men from the
patriarchy by smoking your challenging
male power
so in march 1929 edward made his move
back then the easter day parade in new
york city was a big deal it was as
important to retail sales as christmas
is today high society women will wear
the best fashion and walk down fifth
avenue while being admired by the plebs
lined up on the sides of the streets in
other words the parade acted like an
insane role model that women looked up
to so the new york city easter day
parade became bernay's vehicle for a
cigarette campaign his plan get a group
of good looking but not too good looking
women to spontaneously light up
cigarettes as they walk down the parade
in 1929 this would be the equivalent of
beyonce puffing on a jewel during the
super bowl halftime show so edward sent
out an appeal to the high society women
to light what he called torches of
freedom during the parade in the name of
women's liberation
and everything happened exactly as
planned during the parade one woman
after another started lining up lucky
shrek cigarettes the signature brand of
the american tobacco company and edward
made sure that photographers and
journalists were there to capture it all
edward even got his secretary to pretend
to be part of the movement all to read a
carefully crafted message to the press
about smashing discrimination by smoking
in public
and just a few days after the parade
women took to the streets all over the
u.s smoking their tortures of freedom
the sale of lucky strike cigarettes
tripled within a year
edward bernays and the american tobacco
company had turned a toxic product into
a symbol of freedom big tobacco just got
women to think that smoking in public
was their own idea
[Music]
in cutthroat industries like tobacco new
ideas are constantly being bounced
around for how to make more money or how
to get more people to buy your products
and that's true for almost every other
industry in existence today jumping on a
new trend or craze before it blows up is
what makes people millionaires maybe
even billionaires and if you don't have
the pleasure of being in elite circles
that is where trends comes in trends is
probably one of the most valuable yet
unknown knowledge hubs on the internet
for aspiring entrepreneurs they help you
find your next big business idea or
startup before it explodes here's how it
works trend sends you emerging business
trends months before they pop saving you
from months of research spending
thousands of dollars testing and it
saves you from the feeling of regret of
not starting sooner and not only that
trends then gives you a community that
can help make it happen a community
where you can meet your next co-founder
or investor they've got over 15 000
ambitious and successful people all
rooting for you and your success and to
top it all off trends gives you live
trainings with industry experts to teach
you the best practices and topics like
seo marketing operations fundraising so
you can become a better business
operator and even if you can't make it
live you can access the library of past
trainings all you have to do to get
started is to go to trends.co jake tran
with the link below sign up and enjoy
access to all the biggest and best
trends before the world catches on one
of my favorite features of trends is
their databases that give you inside
information like the funding data for
thousands of successful kickstarter
campaigns or the trends recession
database that can help you find out how
entrepreneurs have found ways to not
just survive but thrive during difficult
economic times to take advantage of
everything trends has to offer go to
trends.co
jaketrans.co.not.com to get a seven-day
trial for just one dollar that's
trends.co slash j train to start your
seven-day trial for just one dollar with
the link below thanks to trends for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
world war one was a great time to be a
tobacco company during the war
cigarettes and tobacco weren't a luxury
they were being subsidized or handed out
for free as part of the tobacco
industry's patriotic duty and the
soldiers ate it up what better way to
calm your nerves in the battlefield than
with cigarettes even army surgeons
praised cigarettes for helping wounded
soldiers stay calm so during the four
years of war sales tripled and when
those soldiers came back home well they
were already addicted to nicotine and
became customers for life it was the
perfect marketing campaign
when world war ii came along you
followed the same business model
cigarettes were handed out were food
rations turning hundreds of thousands of
soldiers into loyal customers but that
wasn't all in 1941 germany banned
smoking in public the germans had lots
of anti-smoking campaigns around the
start of the war because they knew it
was bad for your health obviously you
already knew tobacco wasn't exactly
great for people's health but the
germans had just given you the
opportunity of a lifetime anyone who
would go up against tobacco now could be
labeled anti-american and pro-german
after all what did the germans know
about public health and safety hitler
and mussolini apparently hated tobacco
while the leaders of the free world
churchill roosevelt and stalin were all
heavy smokers the germans and italians
were cruel and hated america that's why
they refused to smoke cigarettes and
believe it or not the rhetoric worked
now more than ever patriotic families
and returning soldiers encouraged
tobacco as just another way to stick it
to the enemy and once again cigarette
sales skyrocketed
in a nationwide survey doctors in all
branches of medicine were asked what
cigarette do you smoke doctor the brand
named most was camels
tens of thousands of doctors general
practitioners surgeons specialists
doctors in every branch of medicine were
included and according to this
nationwide survey more doctors smoke
camels than any other cigarette
try camels yourself the cigarette so
many doctors enjoy
both world wars and the women's rights
movement had done wonders for cigarette
sales but of course it was never enough
you knew cigarettes could become even
bigger and more profitable if only you
could get more people to take their
first puff once they did they would be
hooked so you launched one of the
craziest fast-paced sales campaign in
history you hire doctors and dentists to
endorse your cigarettes to put people at
ease over the health risks you use
slogans like more dr smoke camels based
on a survey taken after giving all the
doctors a free packet of camels
yes according to this repeated
nationwide survey more doctors smoke
camels than any other cigarette quotes
like just what the doctor ordered were
all over cigarette ads
coffee doctor oh fine
have a camel with your coffee thanks
and that wasn't all building off of
edward renee's strategy you took it a
step further and started paying
celebrities to smoke on the big screen
cigarettes were made into something sexy
sophisticated and alluring
the marlboro man made it seem like only
real men smoke cigarettes and campaigns
even went so far as to get kids into
smoking too
they like to use cartoons and symbols to
hook our kids let's take a winston break
dad dad winston is the one filthy
cigarette that delivers flavor 20 times
a pack winston's got that filter play
for over two decades you had free reign
to advertise where you want claim what
you want and do just about anything to
make more money and it worked by the
early 60s 42 percent of americans were
regular smokers this meant you had over
75 million loyal customers
life couldn't be better but then in 1964
a report came out that would bring your
industry to its knees and change the
course of nicotine marketing forever on
january 11 1964 the u.s surgeon general
released his report on the connection
between smoking and cancer basically it
says smoking was a direct cause of lung
cancer in men and women and was one of
the main causes of chronic bronchitis
this sent shockwaves through america
suddenly the government started tripping
over itself to start regulating the same
industry they relied on to keep their
soldiers going just 25 years earlier it
seemed like cigarette sales had come to
a grinding halt something had to be done
you couldn't let decades of hard work
and propaganda go down in flames because
of one doctor's opinion so you went back
to the drawing board and came up with a
strategy to ensure that no matter what
the doctor said you wouldn't stop
selling
that always adds up to real smoking
enjoyment why well first because lucky
strike means fine tobacco and then this
fine good tasting tobacco is toasted to
taste even better cleaner fresher
smoother so anytime you want to lighten
the problem light up a lucky
for the taste that you like light up the
lucky stripes right now
years of lying to the public taught you
one thing if you could sow even the
smallest seed of doubt in people's minds
their addiction to tobacco would
outweigh their medical worries and you
would continue making money the plan was
simple number one you would go on a
smear campaign digging up every little
bit of dirt on the doctors going against
cigarettes no one would listen to a guy
who cheated on his wife make the health
phonetics unlikable and people would
find their own reasons not to believe
them number two overwhelm the public
with scientific data so they wouldn't
know what to believe or what it all
means get hundreds of doctors and
researchers to write opposing reports so
that no one would be totally sure what
the truth is
and number three take the health freaks
on in public send your most likable
spokespeople because if the public likes
you they're less likely to listen to a
quiet uncharismatic scientist who can't
keep their attention for more than 60
seconds
how on earth would big tobacco profit
off of the loss of this young man now i
hate to think in such callous terms but
if anything
we'd be losing a customer
it's not only our hope it's in our best
interest to keep robin alive and smoking
the ron goodies of this world the robin
willigers to die you know why so that
their budgets will go up then big
tobacco started the council for
scientific research a very serious
sounding organization tasked with
investigating the claims against
cigarettes and reminding people that
there was no way to prove this who
provides the financial backing for the
academy of tobacco studies conglomerated
tobacco that's the cigarette companies
for the most part yes these guys
realized quick if they were going to
claim that cigarettes were not addictive
they better have proof he's been testing
the link between nicotine and lung
cancer for 30 years and hasn't found any
conclusive results
the man's a genius he can disprove
gravity
and then just for good measure you
decide to create a new healthier range
of cigarettes that were lighter filtered
roasted or had menthol all these
adjustments made cigarettes healthier
than ever and were obviously a great
alternative to quitting tobacco entirely
your counter attack was working you were
the caring tobacco company who even paid
their own money to find out if
cigarettes were bad you had the
well-being of your customers at heart
but this ruse couldn't last forever
in the 70s the us government had enough
and finally started banning tobacco ads
but that didn't stop you when your ads
were banned on tv you moved them to
newspapers when they were banned from
the media completely you became the
sponsor for sports events and
celebrities banned from advertising in
stores you switched to marketing reps
outside the shops and when the 90s came
around the internet viral marketing and
online sponsorships were a life saver
the message hollywood needs to send out
is smoking is cool we need the cast of
will and grace smoking in their living
room forest gump puffing away between
his box of chocolates most of the actors
smoke already
if they start doing it on screen
we can put the sex back into cigarettes
even after almost every form of
cigarette advertising known to man was
restricted you would find a way to keep
your customer base growing like placing
cigarette display cases at kids eye
levels and taking advantage of poorly
enforced online content policies and of
course by expanding into developing
countries where the restrictions can't
be enforced by 2019 the global sales of
legal tobacco products hit 818 billion
dollars more than 5.2 trillion
cigarettes are smoked a year that's
nearly a million cigarettes every 60
seconds by the time you're done watching
this around 15 million cigarettes have
been smoked depending on the length of
this video and even after all the
anti-marketing campaigns nearly 20
percent of adults still choose to light
up and with the advent of healthier
options like e-cigarettes and vaping big
tobacco seems to have found a brand new
angle to exploit
now big tobacco may sound bad but the
truth is most companies governments and
organizations after money and power do
this exact same kind of code calculated
thinking they just never admitted to the
public for obvious reasons and that's
what we tried to dive into on this
channel so you too can profit from the
same kind of machiavellian thinking if i
were a startup i would say we're
democratizing the pursuit of money and
power but the thing is some of this
stuff is just a tad bit too dark to post
publicly that's why you should click the
join button below or the link below if
you don't see the join button by joining
you'll get access to exclusive
documentaries going over how the world
really works there are two controversial
to ever be released to the public this
month's private documentary is going to
be on mk ultra the government's
incredibly unethical mind control
program that full disclosure is probably
going to be a little delayed because my
posting schedule this holiday season is
really really packed and rumor has it
the one after that is going to be on our
friend efree jepstein we already have
one out on monsanto the company that
owns the world's food supply that you
can watch right now when you join and
you can always preview the ones out
already without being a member with this
link below so click the join button
below right now for the knowledge
they'll never teach you in business
school for just five dollars a month if
you join and don't think it's worth it
email me and i'll personally refund you
the money sign up today with the join
button below
do
you